look at this fella
um
how's that for a resemblance say hello
to Gus Gutfeld the king of late night
has welcomed an adorable French Bulldog
into his home this weekend so welcome
Greg to the five's dog owners Club it's
great to have you we you know a lot of
us have dogs not Jessica not yet she's
gonna get one I got a little gift for
Gus there's a Halloween bandana and a
little octopus for when he gets a little
bit older is a his first unicorn soccer
ball wow that's awesome it's very
strange I haven't slept because all he
does is we're crate training him so all
he does is scream in this demonic whale
it's a tiny little guy but his seat
screaming it's screaming look I look
like a mess it's so cute
yeah I have noticed a change in you
already look at that grin look at how
warm that's the best picture that by the
way those are not my legs
[Laughter]
yeah just sleeping there he does that so
you can't move but uh that is a very
cute the great thing I learned about
dogs is like their poop doesn't really
smell their pee doesn't smell you know I
kind of forget about washing my hands
after a while
it's still toxic do you have any good
advice for raising a puppy I have a good
advice so I don't know if you have a
Roomba Greg but if you do never turn it
on with the puppy while you're out of
the house what happens because if the
puppy has an accident
your whole house will be room bud and it
will smell did that happen to you it may
have happened oh my gosh yeah and Roomba
won't give you a new one they're like
yeah it happens all the time I don't
know does he have any advice no I have
no advice what did you why did you go
with the French Bulldog because there is
a resemblance well that's the way that's
the first thing my wife said when I sent
the picture she goes he looks just like
you but you know I I tested out cat has
a cat tymph you know like she's the
blonde lady from the Gutfeld show yeah
she has she and her husband got uh is
the uncle the Carl their dog is my dog's
Uncle oh okay so here's the nephew
different I think it's same father
different Mom I don't know they're all
[ __ ] but these dogs you know they just
sleep with everybody I have some good
advice yes and I learned this from the
monks of New York they raised there's
his monks and they raise German
Shepherds to be service dogs they have
in their book a tip that I've given to
people that's very good when he's a
little bit older you want to take him to
a place that's a little unfamiliar like
a wooded area like maybe up at the uh
you know where a state yes I'm familiar
for Greg take him to a church
and you want to take them off the leash
and let him sort of sniff around and
sort of forget about you right and then
what you do dive behind a tree and you
wait for a moment for him to get a
little like nervous like looking for you
then step behind out and say hi I'm
right here and he will never take his
eyes off of you and it helps a lot oh
interesting very good do you know uh
other pieces of advice I remember this
from Scott Adams talking about how to
deal with dogs barking that they're not
the same language as you it's like if
the the best um analogy to a dog or
puppy barking is when you're pressing a
doorbell and nobody's home or you're
pressing a button to get a candy bar out
of the vending machine it's just it's
just it's not as hard up for that it's
just pushing a button that's what
they're doing they're trying to they're
like that's so that now when I think
about that it doesn't bother pressure is
my button so I had to I had to try to
get Johnny to ask someone if they could
have rookies voice box
I didn't know apparently that's
considered a barbaric Pursuit I didn't
know
the eyes of who's raising a baby
[Laughter]
is it just amazing how much attention
you're getting on the street because
that dog you probably can't even get
down to the corner yeah I walked down to
some pet shop and I had him in my little
just a pocket and everybody there was
like and it kind of Jesse you wouldn't
be able to handle this because the fame
goes away from you to this dog
it's like it was like before people
would stop me on the street hug me tell
me I changed their life but now it's
just the little dog when they pay
attention to rookie instead of me I go
I'm waters you know what it is when it's
me and I'm alone it's just fans from 65
70 year old ladies but when I got the
dog that's all the models and they don't
even see me
congratulations hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else